[Music]
so
thank you guys all for for coming to
this meeting
i just have a very just a quick little
announcement that we might be having
a few new additions to the family
i know i know by this time normally
we would have already had our new family
member here but
it's okay things have been delayed it's
been a crazy year
you guys have all been through a lot
we've all been through a lot together
and i'm glad that we could be here
because on october 13th that is when we
will find out more
about our new friend
i know i'm really excited too do you
guys have any questions can i answer
anything for you any concerns
oh will it have usbc i don't know i'm
not going to get into rumors
i feel like that's something that i've
done in the past and now
nearing the moment that we're going to
find out all the information i don't
want to i don't want any more spoilers
i don't i just it's a good question
that's fair anybody else
no this does not mean that we love you
any less it just means we have a new
member of the family this has nothing to
do
with the fact that you're not 5g or this
has nothing to do with that it's just
and i understand your concern i
completely i get it if anybody gets it
i get it
okay i hope that we're all very excited
for this moment
it's something that we've all been
waiting for and i look forward to
bringing home our new family member
members for you guys all to meet them
thank you for coming to this meeting
maybe and then maybe look up the camera
and be like okay that was silly but
let's talk about the new iphone
no that's it the video is over oh that's
the video that's it oh okay
no i'm just kidding i don't really know
um guys i don't even know what to say
really i'm just really excited for the
new iphone obviously this is something
that i look forward to
it's basically i revolve my entire year
around when the iphone is going to be
launched
and i think we really did expect this to
be released later
we don't really know there's so many
rumors out there and i've kind of
stopped looking at the rumors i know
i've made a couple rumor videos before
i just kind of want to be surprised i
mean i know what i've read i know what
i've reported to you guys
that i've seen online but at this point
i'm done no more looking it is as i'm
recording this it's tuesday
october 6th and i'll be posting
september 7th
and at that point you know we're going
to wait until the 13th the big event
they sent the invites out today on
tuesday the 6th
and it's crazy because i woke up this
morning and as i was walking the dog my
first thought
was feels like iphone season like i just
sensed it i tweeted and then 50 minutes
later
in my email i received the invite to the
high comma speed and my sister jenna
actually sent me her invite first
because i was busy editing and then i
saw her text message come through
and i this is really silly but
i thought that they had like mistyped
her name and i thought that they were
calling her
speed like hi speed or hi justine hi
jenna and it took me a second to realize
no they were saying hello to speed
because that must mean something speedy
is around the corner which i think at
this point
we're all pretty well aware that 5g is
the future and the next iphone
or iphones will most likely be 5g
i i mean what but maybe it's 120 hertz
but it's true will we have 120hz display
will we finally get a usbc
charger in the iphone i feel like if
they do put a usbc charger in it's going
to be in the pro models i feel like some
of the lower end models
i had said i wasn't going to go get into
talking about rumors but i feel like i
kind of just have to there's supposed to
be four iphones
there's gonna be a mini oh my gosh i
just don't know
what's what i've read i've seen it ah a
mini iphone
like what size do we think the mini
would be do we think it would be the
size of the original iphone
could you imagine this little mini
iphone
with like a full like oled retina like
an updated version of this
could you like this if this was updated
into a today version of something
similar to
i mean this is kind of more along the
lines i feel like of what the rumors
that i've seen
this more kind of a boxy edge design
which i do
really really like but there is
something so beautiful about this
original iphone
like it is just so iconic like if they
went back
and did a re-release of this iphone as a
new
generation phone apple if you're not
thinking about it if like this is
something that you weren't thinking
about before and i just planted the seed
like please
let it let it grow let it flourish i
think
i mean maybe i might be the only one
that buys it but that's okay
it's okay anyway
i'm looking forward to it it's also
gonna be crazy because
you know last year we were all
celebrating together the release and the
announcement of the new iphone and
we're back to doing the digital thing
again and i think apple's been doing a
really incredible job of their digital
events
a lot of companies have really
completely changed the way
that they're doing events and i think
people are really stepping it up but i
think apple
there's a fly so big oh god he's so
massive
there he is there he goes he's out
i have been very impressed with a lot of
the press briefings that i've attended
virtually
for tons of different companies so i
think apple has been really setting the
bar because
obviously theirs have by far been the
absolute best
maddie agrees apple has been doing such
an incredible job that they have my god
there are so many flies
in my house i keep the door open so the
dog can go in and out
even the flies also go in and out
it's so big it's a different one he's
he's a different shape
so in conclusion
let's freaking get hyped up man october
13th i'll see you guys
on the internet that's it that's it the
end of the video
okay kids do you guys want to go to the
park
gosh so many beautiful phones this is
still one of my favorite gold colors
like this oh like it's just beautiful
all right well i guess say i put these
guys back
where i got them don't worry i'll bring
you guys back out on the 13th
we can celebrate together maddie
he's an iphone actually he has an ipad
it's from dj set
i know i clearly have issues